sie werden wir jubel sie gewinnen
millionen von dollar an preisgeld sie
haben eigene trainingslager taktiker
manager und analysten wie nur daran
arbeiten sie immer besser zu machen
dabei reisen sie um die ganze welt um in
eigens dafür gebauten stadien vor
tausenden fans zu spielen und all das
mit dem was normale leute zum spaß in
ihrer freizeit machen die sportler
kriegen wieder traumberuf schlechthin
wer würde sich nicht gerne dafür
bezahlen einfallen lassen und dafür dass
man sein lieblingsspielzeug aber ist das
ganze wirklich so einfach oder ist das
doch harte arbeit ist das talent oder
training und macht das dann überhaupt
noch spaß
ich war nie gut in schuttern ich habe
zum beispiel noch nie counterstrike
gespielt hatte trotz mehrerer
spielstunden damals keinen einzigen
vorteil solulin und eine kg also killed
the trade von 0,83 um das zu ändern
werde ich zuerst meine leistungen im
ego-shooter csg und dann in vorderrad
auf den prüfstand stellen dann eine
woche speziellen trainings software
benutzen und auswertungen meiner
performance annan von graphen
analysieren und danach natürlich erneut
man leistungen in den spielen messen am
ende werde ich gegen erstens einen der
größten fordert youtuber und zweitens
einem 17-jährigen vorgänger antreten der
in turnieren bereits mehrere tausend
euro gewonnen an
dieses video wird unterstützt von huawei
bestandsaufnahme ich bin schlecht aber
wie ich schlecht genau also ich habe ja
schon mal gespielt
vor zwei jahren nach ist dafür habe ich
ihn gewonnen habe ich nicht im ok hahaha
bitte lass mir im leben patronen
gefunden
okay nicht tut mir nein ok jetzt mal
allerersten mal counter strike mal
schauen wie gut ich da so bin was genau
macht eigentlich einen spieler gut es
gibt dutzende komponenten movement
strategie schlaue tastenbelegung in
fordert zum beispiel das bauen in allen
schultern aber die wichtigste ist wohl
der aim to aim bedeutet wörtlich zielen
wird aber in einem satz zum beispiel so
verwendet thomas hat keinen aim
man könnte also mit zielwasser
übersetzen
ja das war als mal nicht in fordern haid
hatte ich in den zehn matches eine kg
von 0,89 wurde durchschnittlich platz 57
und habe drei minuten und 18 sekunden
überlebt den csv wusste ich nicht was
ich mich da bauen wir anstellen mussten
dann mit einer kg von 0,58 noch
schlechter aber die beste taktik bringt
mir nichts wenn ich am ende vom gegner
stehe und den einfach nicht greift
deswegen habe ich jetzt jedes mal einen
trainer
das ist heftig gibt mir in der
auswertung wo ich immerhin man sieht ja
richtig schön die grünen treffe ich und
team rauschenden nicht daran muss ich
jetzt üben dass sie möglichst viel grün
treffen trainer kann ich zu oft schießen
üben die ich möchte ohne sterben zu
können oder spieler suchen zu müssen
auf diese art kann ich in ruhe die
beiden wichtigsten grundbausteine vom
digitalen zielwasser affleck shorts also
mit der maus möglichst schnell und
präzise das fadenkreuz auf den gegner
katapultieren und tracking also an den
gegner präzise mit dem fadenkreuz zu
verfolgen
im vergleich zu vorher ist wirklich viel
präziser jetzt mittlerweile schon ein
paar stunden
ich glaube soll man schlafen gehen
heute zieht es mich auch schon weg von
meinem setup und zwar hier mit zu meinen
eltern über die autobahn
boa war unser heutiger sponsor hat mir
dafür dass neue macbooks pro geschickt
mit dem ich auch mobil zum beispiel eben
beim besuch meiner eltern effektiv
arbeiten und hier zum beispiel ein
thumbnail in photoshop erstellen kann
das unfassbar leichte und kompakte
notebook aus metall verschwindet
unauffällig in jedem rucksack und auf
den dreikampf view display ist dank der
hohen auflösung von 3000 mal 2000 pixeln
trotzdem mehr als genug platz für
fenster menüs und ordner für dich sonst
einen zweiten monitor projekte gerade
für das kreative arbeiten ist der multi
touchscreen perfekt zum beispiel zum
scrollen oder zoomen von bildern ein
weiteres highlight ist die kamera welche
per knopfdruck einfach außer tastatur
erscheint und genauso diskret auch
wieder verschwindet damit konnte ich
auch an diesem wochenende streamen und
mit dem intel core i7 prozessor der
zehnten generation und der nvidia
geforce fx 250 grafikkarte kann ich
jetzt natürlich auch von unterwegs weil
meine eltern fordert üben mehr infos
findet ihr über den link unten in der
video beschreibung guten morgen ich
wollte gerade zocken und das ihm
aufgefallen ich habe eine maus perfektes
nase muss ich ein bisschen improvisieren
und habe jetzt ein brett
hierzu gehört er zum deutschen trainer
gefunden nachdem ich mit dem alten nicht
so zufrieden weil er war ein bisschen
langsam und unübersichtlich dein gegen
gefällt mir das ja ziemlich stark und
die statistiken dabei sind auch richtig
cool man schauen was er so drauf hat
[Musik]
das jetzt auf meine skaten game auswirkt
ich habe getroffen ich treffe einfach
macht das bild sie an wie diesem moment
weiß beide werden wo er einfach
plötzlich keine brille mehr braucht und
mega stark ist komplett das gefühl dass
ich das einmal jetzt schon ein bisschen
kann wenn man das macht desto mehr nimmt
einfach die konzentration und hat damit
auch die leistung drastisch haben
ich brauche eine pause in der
zwischenzeit lass ich mal meine eltern
versuchen die noch nie ein computerspiel
gespielt haben
ich musste auf die sachen drauf
schließen
die queen nimmt auch die blauen genau
wusste beide treffen dann muss ich denn
da hinter dem ausbau weg nach rechts
nach rechts jetzt mit dem mit dem kreuz
auf die bälle dem kreuz das bin ich der
wiener oder erst einmal außer den
interessenten
mit thomas seine eltern zur spielsucht
zwei programmen geboren und sie haben
sich innerhalb ihrer ersten drei
versuche drastisch gesteigert mein vater
zb von circa 14.000 auf 24.000 punkte um
ganze 68 prozent jetzt wird es ernst
aber bevor es richtig ernst wird werde
ich mich erstmal einem trainer auf und
schauen mal wie sehr ich mich da
verbessert habe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der war schon mal bisher der beste
aufnahme ab
[Musik]
aber wie sich das jetzt auch das spiel
auswirkt das ist jetzt die frage
wir fangen an mit vor neid aber jetzt
auch das bauen einfluss dass ich fast
gar nicht geübt habe mal schauen wie
mein training bei csg hilft da wo sie
nur um sein wird in vor neid konnte ich
meine kg von 0,89 auf 1,2 oben ganze 35
prozent verbessern
durchschnittlich bin ich zwei plätze
besser und habe neun sekunden länger
überlegt in counter-strike also cs go wo
es nicht ums bauen geht sondern fast nur
um same konnte ich durch das training
meine kg sogar um 153 prozent steigern
von 0,58 auf 1,47 ich habe mich deutlich
verbessert aber wie werde ich gegen
einen echten programme abschneiden wir
finden es heraus
es ist 17 und im fast wöchentlich an
turnieren teil bei denen es um fünf bis
sechsstellige beträge geht aber
überzeugt euch selbst als erstes 25
kills hat gewinnt
nein okay das ist so lächerlich ich weiß
überhaupt nicht was abgeht
ja wir haben ja gut getroffen
ich sagte ein krieg
nein das wollen wir nicht
ach das war eigentlich nach dieser reihe
na ja also das gehören ok ok gegen einen
pro gamer habe ich also keine chance der
trainiert aber ja auch schon seit
mehreren jahren mindestens so hart wie
ich aber kann ich denn mit nur einer
woche von diesem harten training
jemanden schlagen der seit mehreren
jahren normal spielt die drei disco
marne okay jetzt mal ernst machen ich
weiß du wolltest mich geradezu an führt
dann ein bisschen nach die ersten fünf
teams schenke ich immer das auch ist
auch wichtig meine du bist ja die zeit
ja was hast du mir gerade 14 was alles
hätte schutzgrad oder ich würde ich erst
mal finden
aha dann lässt du nicht ein
vielleicht hat eigentlich alles
gegenstand das geld habe ich also auch
kassiert 25 zu 9 ging es aus bei ford
spielt das bauen halt doch eine riesige
rolle und ich hätte vielleicht ein paar
übungen dazu nehmen sollen aber trotzdem
konnte ich auch hier money kg steigern
um 35 prozent auf 1,2 übrigens jedes mal
wenn ein spieler in kiel macht steht
eine andere spieler zusätzlich kann man
natürlich auch noch durch verschiedene
andere szenarien sterben das heißt dass
die durchschnittliche kw bei fordert
unter 1 liegen muss und nicht
automatisch besser als der durchschnitt
bin richtig gezogen an mein
trainingsplan mir gesagt bei
counterstrike aber auch um hier richtig
gut zu werden braucht zeit ein bisschen
mehr als hier weil jedoch eine woche
schon etwas knapp geworden apropos zeit
eine da frage ich mich am anfang
gestellt habe ist ob es überhaupt noch
spaß macht wenn man die ganze zeit
nichts anderes macht als auf leistung zu
gehen und den spaß eben hinten anstellt
und ich muss schon recht sagen dass das
ein training mega entspannt war um
nebenbei podcasts hören und abzuschalten
und auch wenn ich wahnsinnigen respekt
vor menschen wie rias habe bleibe ich
auf dauer wohl doch lieber casual
gelegenheitsspieler zumindest bis jetzt
bei das tagesgeld multiplayer ab teilt
rauskommt den link zum huawei mails book
expo findet ihr in der video beschreibt
wenn jetzt lust hat auf noch ein video
dann könnt ihr gerne auf meine zweite
kanal vorbei schauen sich jeden zweiten
tagen video nicht als jede woche
abonniert mich auch gerne auf diesem
kanal wenn ihr mich auf dieser reise
begleiten möchte und dann sehen wir
zunächst mal wieder macht's gut
[Musik]